está dando el paso se están dando unos
pasos muy importantes como ya se ha
señalado aquí uno presentarle estas
recomendaciones a la sociedad colombiana
y decirnos todas las personas todos los
sectores tuvimos en cierta medida
responsabilidad de que esta tragedia se
perpetuará en el tiempo por supuesto la
responsabilidad del estado es mucho
mayor dado su compromiso y su obligación
de garantizar el gozo efectivo de
derechos en un país No creo yo que esto
Da inicio en un ámbito propicio también
políticamente hablando que lo que se ve
planteaba de Gustavo Petro Francia
Márquez a la cabeza del ejecutivo da pie
para el inicio de estas transformaciones
y continuar con la implementación
integral del acuerdo de paz tan golpeado
por el gobierno Duque y por los sectores
que este gobierno Duque y el uribismo
representan no y básicamente
plantea también el escenario de Cuáles
han sido las principales tensiones que
ha tenido la comisión de la verdad
durante su funcionamiento entonces uno
dice desde el legislativo se ha venido
atacando todos los avances en materia de
la del sistema integral de verdad
justicia reparación en una repetición se
atacó financieramente la comisión de la
verdad se ha venido atacando a través de
campañas mediáticas y se ha intentado
difamar a sus miembros se ha intentado
deslegitimar su trabajo entonces hay
todo un sector político que ha venido
atacando de manera sistemática toda la
posibilidad de implementación de la
cuerda ese sector ya para el próximo
gobierno Pues no va a ser el sector que
tome las decisiones en el nivel político
y en el nivel digamos tampoco Parece ser
que lo va a tomar en el legislativo
Entonces tenemos un ambiente propicio
vamos seguramente a iniciar un tránsito
en donde todos debemos poner unos
nosotros por supuesto Y en donde ya
veremos De qué manera Por ejemplo los
grupos armados ilegales oyen este
llamado de no más guerra no más
violencia y Esperamos que también se
desarrollen unos mecanismos por ejemplo
de sometimiento a la justicia o que se
reforme esa ley con el propósito de que
hayan más incentivos para que los
grandes carteles o grandes
organizaciones de crimen organizado como
el clan del Golfo se desmantelen Incluso
se ha propuesto que sea de manera
colectiva eso ya lo veremos es un
proceso largo que ahorita se ponen unos
elementos muy importantes y hay un
espacio un escenario propicio para este
proceso pero no va a ser de la noche a
la mañana tenemos muchos desafíos